now let's think a little bit about
expressions with more than one variable
so let's say i had the expression a
a plus b
and i were to ask you what is this
expression equal to when a is equal to
five and b
and b is equal to seven well in that
situ in this situation this expression
would be instead of an a we would have a
five and it would be five
plus instead of a b we would have
we would have a 7. so it would be 5 plus
7
is equal to 12. now let's try another
expression let's say we had the
expression
10
times
x
10 times x
minus
minus 3 times
3 times i'll do a blue y
minus 3 times y and let's think about
what would this expression evaluate a2
when x is equal to negative 1
and when y
y is equal to 5. well let's just
evaluate it we'd have 10 times
10 times 7x we now know that x is equal
to negative 1.
it'd be 10 times
negative 1
10 times negative 1
minus 3 times 5. so 3 times instead of a
y we're going to put a 5 there minus 3
times 5 and so 10 times negative 1 that
is negative 10
and we're going to subtract from that 3
times 5. you want to do the
multiplication first by order of
operations that's the convention 3 times
5 is 15.
3 times 5 is 15 so it's negative 10
minus 15 which is equal to negative
negative 25.
and now
you have the next exercise to practice
some of these a little bit more